les violons urbaines qui sont qui se
sont déroulées entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet dernier si elles peuvent nous
interroger sur diverses politiques
publiques posent la question dans
l'urgence de veiller à la continuité et
la stabilité de leur public et du
service public
pour ce faire il nous a paru impératif
de réparer et de remettre en état dans
les plus progrès délais les équipements
publics et les quelques 750 bâtiments
publics et trois fois plus de bâtiments
privés qui ont été abîmés et dégradés au
cours de ces événements
si nous ne connaissons pas la
répartition exacte de ces dégradations
en termes d'ampleur et de gravité il est
certain qu'un grand nombre de travaux
vont devoir être rapidement lancés pour
permettre leur réflexion ou le
reconstruction complète
c'est à cette tâche impérieuse et
urgente que vise à réponses projet de
loi alors même que le gouvernement après
la mise en œuvre notamment par deux
circulaires de la première ministre de
première mesure d'accélération le projet
de loi se compose de trois articles
d'habilitation qui porte chacun sur une
composante essentielle des travaux de
reconstruction en effet bien que le
temps presse ces mesures dérogatoires
nécessiteront un travail d'expertise
approfondi qui justifie le passage par
ordonnance avec un délai limite de
publication fixé à brève échéance la
rédaction des habilitations qui nous est
présentée sur laquelle nos collègues
sénateurs dont je salue le travail ont
déjà travaillé et précises et ciblées
pour
permettra de dérogations
précises et limitée l'article premier
abilique le gouvernement apprend par
voie d'ordonnance les mesures propres à
accélérer la reconstruction et la
réflexion des bâtiments dégradés lors de
violence urbaines d'abord pour autoriser
le reconstruction identique ou sous
réserve de modifications limité et
d'amélioration justifiée même si les
règles d'urbanisme en vigueur s'y
opposent ensuite pour permettre
l'engagement de travaux préliminaires
d'avant la délivrance de l'autorisation
d'urbanisme ou la décision de non
opposition à la déclaration préalable
enfin pour accélérer en passant par
exemple de six mois à 6 semaines le
traitement des demandes d'autorisation
d'urbanisme y compris en ce qui concerne
les consultations de différentes
instances autorité qui peuvent être
impliquées dans sa délivrance l'article
2 habilite le gouvernement instauré un
régime dérogatoire à certaines règles de
la commande publique pour les marchés de
travaux sur les bâtiments concernés
permettrait aux acheteurs publics
premièrement de passer des marchés
publics sans publicité mais avec mise en
concurrence pour des travaux dans le
montant sur inférieur à un seuil défini
dans l'ordonnance et qui serait
nettement supérieur aux droits communs
qui jouent le rappelle de 100000 euros
deuxièmement il s'agirait de permettre
aux acheteurs publics de ne pas alertir
leur marché dans certains cas cette
faculté pourrait permettre un gain de
plusieurs mois l'article 3 habilite le
gouvernement à faciliter le financement
par les collectivités territoriales des
travaux de réparation et de
reconstruction nécessaire il s'agit il
s'agira notamment d'abord de pouvoir
déterminer des modalités particulières
de versement des instributions destinaux
bénéficiaires du Fonds de compensation
pour la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée le
fameux FCTVA au titre des dépenses
éligibles un financement dans ce cadre
il s'agit ainsi de permettre le
versement contemporain du FCTV en année
N ensuite l'article prévoit de déroger
aux exigences de participation minimale
des collectivités territoriales mettre
d'ouvrage au financement de leurs
projets d'investissement pour leur
permettre de bénéficier de subventions
pouvant aller jusqu'à 100% du coût des
travaux ces dispositifs permettront une
véritable facilitation et une
accélération du financement des travaux
contribuant à soulager les collectivités
et leur tension de trésorerie il s'agit
donc là de mesure qui accompagnent
utilement la mise en place du front de
financement de travaux préparés par la
circulaire de la première ministre
j'estime que ces dispositions sont
nécessaires et proportionnées et je vous
proposerai comme la commission des
affaires économiques qui a CGR d'atopter
le texte sans modification bien sûr
au-delà du travail de reconstruction la
restauration de nos quartiers devra vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre devra
aussi être mené sur le long terme et les
problématiques de ces territoires
abordés bien plus largement mais ce
projet de loi nous permet d'aborder
utilement les problèmes les plus urgents
je